I am concerned, should I be concerned if my cancer antigen CA 2729 blood test result
is 22.4, range is 0 to 38.6 and 22.4 on the CA 153 range 0 to 25, they both seem to
be climbing a little each time tested.
So with any blood test you're looking at trends, should that cause concern if I'm trending
up on two of my tumor markers?
So one of the two markers that is fairly specific to breast cancer, CA 2729 and the other one
fairly specific to breast cancer, CA 153 are trending up but are still within normal range
of this person, should they be concerned?
I would say it depends, it depends, you compare that with other objective findings.
What does the rest of my blood work look like?
If I get a more ademic on a CDC with differential, no, that stayed steady, I'm good with that.
I have a more, you know, any changes in my comprehensive metabolic profile, you know,
is my, I'll go and phosphatase up, is my, are my other liver markers up, is my calcium
levels up?
No, those are all fine.
And subjective data by feeling worse, no, I'm feeling great, I'm feeling, I'm just as
much energy as before, with the breast tumor, can I palpate it any more than before?
No, it doesn't feel any bigger or anything, then I would say no, you don't need to worry
about it all, well, first of all, I'd say you don't need to worry at all anyhow because
that will do us no good, but should I be concerned to look a little deeper, baby, I would look
at those things, if, if a normal, if my tumor markers were within normal limits, but were
trending slightly upwards, and you know, also accompanied me feeling worse, you know, I
feel like the, the nodule is getting larger, the tumor is getting bigger by breast, and
there was other changes in other blood work, yeah, then we should look at that as, we need
to dig a little deeper.
So you compare that with other things, these are still within normal limits, so that's something
to be alarmed at anyhow, but you want to be wise.
So I would compare that with other objective and subjective data before I'd come back